[Music]
my [__] f Facebook look at the stock
is going down Facebook's full of [__]
ads you can smell the twins on there
what are those two twins doing then they
buy a house they sell in the house and
oh the wink of Vos twins oh God [__]
winky Vos twins these [__]
Momos I'm surprised you even knew about
them I was trying to think of who you're
talking about who the [__] you think
you're dealing with do I've seen social
network [__] I've seen it a couple
times I can't put up with the guy that
plays the thief I like uh Justin Timber
what's the kid name that plays the
[__] thief [__] Eisenberg yeah he he
always has a look on his face like
somebody [__] farted speaking about
[__] farting we finished the podcast
the other day let's go get some [__]
coffee or something now the whole
morning you know before you before you
need the [__] like we getting up early
right now so I'm not even in my [__]
Zone the [__] Zone starts about 7:30 qu
a right before church so it's early so I
got to eat breakfast first drink a few
cups of coffee maybe smoke a number and
I'm ready to take a [__] dumpster and
I walk outside with Lee and and I had a
rip one I didn't want to go in this car
you ever have somebody farting and bring
the [__] fart into their [__] into
your car nothing pisses me off more than
that somebody farts in the hallway and
they bring it air it out out there so I
blow this [__] tremendous fart like
I'm going to blow right now
listen just like that I blow a [__]
number but you can't he Lee heard it in
the car oh my God I heard it in the car
I'm a [__] real Jew I'm not going to
go in there with that ass stink around
my Muffler I'm out there airing the leg
out I'm pumping it like a [__] dog
and as I look I see a lady about 30 ft
away and she's about 90 years old like a
Spanish grandmother and she's walking as
slowly like picture any old woman
walking across the street that's her I
get into the [__] car and I go Lee
this poor lady's about to walk into the
fog of [__] deck and sure enough as
she walks into the Zone I see her pick
her head up and just start going like
this like she smells it now if she made
a face that was perfect perfect now if
you were inside the house and somebody
smelled your fart that's one thing but
when you're outside there air and cre
and Chlor fill it sucks up the farts and
[__] like that you still bump into a
fart that was a [__] good fart what
about the one I just kicked right in oh
my God there's no you're going to have
to throw that chair out but that it's it
didn't what you just said it didn't even
give it justice that woman her face
turned up and she was waving at the air
like it was mustard gas or something it
wasn't just oh that's a bad smelling
fart she was you probably ruined her day
let me tell you something people I hope
you're up don't forget let's say church
starts at 7:30 it's 6:18 right now it's
9:18 on the East Coast either you're
walking out of church you're going to
[__] Denny's to stand online like a
moo or you're going to go out through
your car smoke a number and think about
whatever the [__] the priest or the
[__] Deacon or the [__] Rabbi had
to say well the Jews go to church
yesterday went in the [__] Temple that's
special they go to Temple with Prince
you know what I'm
saying
so like right now today I got to get the
[__] out of here in about an hour I'll
go in there I see Padre throw a [__]
blessing on him put a couple dollars in
the basket I'm out of there in a [__]
half but who else comes on before church
to get you ready mentally for what the
[__] they're going to talk about only
Joey Diaz like today what the [__]
they're going to talk about [__]
Peter and Paul I don't give a [__] I've
heard the story 80 times but I go I take
a couple rips off this and that's it
it's all over but the [__] shot and
the funny thing
was now that's tremendous loving the
Church of What's Happening Now I heard
the part here in Wales technology you
understand me that's how my muff I got
the people always say Joey speak closer
to the [__] microphone these are air
tight [__] microphones you can talk
anyone in the room they get you it's
like a [__] FBI microphone Jesus
Christ speaking of which man let me tell
you something I watch some college
football what a lot of people don't know
is one of the kids I grew up with is now
the uh the head defensive coordinator of
p uh Penn State Jesus Christ of uh Miami
really yeah they [__] won big
yesterday that was pretty good I watched
that for a little while but there's no
Pro today right no no it starts next
week now let me explain something to you
if see if if you let's say you're a pro
[__] gam professional gam you're
getting up right now the first game
could be a two who gives a [__] you're
getting up now you're going to get your
day started you're going to look at the
paper you're going to go online see
who's hurt you're going to do some
[__] Voodoo maybe throw a curse on
the [__] quarterback and you're up
early [__] watching those dumb TV shows
they're steering you to a [__] loser
those [__] that the kiss of death
you don't see them putting no [__]
bets on nothing so now you're getting up
you're getting early that [__] don't
start this week next week is the [__]
kill all these NFL junky [__]
will'll be up ready to rock where's my
cats at these
[__] these are the treats they
like right here [__] Temptations is
tastes like milk or whatever they got
all different flavors look at them
nobody's getting cond in for this [__]
these little [__] they got up
early with me I got up there was like
two of them up already oh yeah you said
they're up all night well they all night
if they get encouragement at like four
they tap out they go [__] it there's
nobody here to rock the house where's
Uncle Joey where's the Bender but I tell
you what you have no idea when you come
home at night you have cats because this
[__] listen my wife goes to
about at 9:00 it's not even my wife I'm
worried about it's the [__] cats I
come home I got a female cat that just
sits there and harasses me you want to
lower that [__] in
there what are you going to do things
are things are bad all over I just
bumped my headphon come here where the
[__] are these cats I got to get some
Fidel get over here one of you little
[__] get over here and [__] I got
treats I'm giving
her come here Dy come here Dy
Temptations treats I got the [__]
check this [__] out I got oh
[__] there's my boy see he's all
scared to me I don't know what problem
there you go JY I got the cat by myself
yeah once one comes in they all come in
yeah no they coming to see me now the
one guy's nervous you should have called
me I would have opened the door for you
when you knock he he goes [__]
bananas oh okay come here Harry say
hello to the people at home C come here
knuckle sandwich get over here this is
what happens early in the morning you
got to say hello to the cats the animals
or nothing it's [__] Sunday so don't
forget to get your oatmeal you want to
start the week off right with the
muffler you know what I'm saying come
here Harry come say hello to the [__]
people on TV I love this little guy here
don't forget if you want to drive your
cats crazy right here it's on uh Amazon
it's called pet green catnip buds these
buds look [__] good too thank God I
don't drink I come home and [__] roll
one of these things up look at this it's
not a [__] tree or something like
that come on no it's big and I I work in
Beverly Hills the one night I'm out
there a week thank God Justin Beverly
Hills a hit that's it nowhere else well
that's that's where it's that's like
where theend the center of it was and
there around there but yeah right in
center of Beverly Hills yeah holy [__]
see that people [__] earthquakes I
don't even know what the [__] going on
and you know what that's what it means
to be part of the church what's
happening now I don't give a [__] I was
driving I was at a Mexican bar last
night where they really killed [__]
anybody I'm lucky I got out of there
alive I went down to do some benefit for
some kid in the [__] wheelchair or
some [__] I thought they were going to
kill me but anyway I made it home my
life What's happen Labor Day weekend
nobody's got to go to work we're right
here with the Church of What's Happening
Now sparking we got music we got movies
we got everything sports today we got
everything you know what I'm saying only
there was no NFL NFL still Thursday
correct I think I think the Giants and
the Cowboys are playing Wednesday maybe
yeah it's like they're getting the
[__] gambling started early it's a
bad [__] economy so let's spark
the holy smoke this is a white debt from
[__] Divine Wellness I know you
people are saying Joey what the [__]
they're supposed to close the weed
stores this week they ain't closing dick
what happened was I guess they had to
have an addendum of
25,000 they got 50,000 signatures so
they're pushing it back till [__] St
janiro day and you know what it didn't
mean much to me because I knew they
weren't going to close them guys look at
allot you people like a you
[__] are out there selling weed
illegally let me explain something to
you they voted and me they wanted to
have like uh people work on [__]
their own grass or some [__] like you
had to do your own growing that's the
new thing they're going to close the
stores I guess and you got to grow your
own weed do I look like Dr Green [__]
thumb to you no one's going to do that
I've never grown [__] dick in my life
I tried growing weed one time and I
smoked it before it hatched I smoked it
like when it was real small I could hat
could I could it's like Christmas
[__] day I couldn't wait to smoke it
and I let it dry and the only thing
that's going to do is make is bring back
the drug dealers and make it worse it's
going to create more crime for them they
can arrest more people listen who gives
a [__] they're still drug dealers no
matter what the problem is that you know
what it's nice we're already used to it
for me I get weed no matter what I don't
give a [__] if you close them let them
open light them on fire it ain't going
to stop Mr flavor I've been smoking
since 79 yeah flavor ain't going to stop
now because you closed the stores and
neither a lot of people now let me ask
you this I uh I smoke a little bit but
in California since it's legal are there
still weed dealers I mean I know they're
dealing other stuff but do you think
there's weed dealer still yeah some
people don't want to get a license some
people don't want
that it's pays to smoke the best [__]
the lung [__] the lung when you're
smoking good reefa [__] and I have the
vaporizer I'm trying to keep it healthy
lately but for you guys in the morning I
smoke a bone because hey we're all
smoking a bone not everybody has a
vaporize I'm going the city like [__]
thirst and H the Third you know oh my
God I'm so [__] you we're all together
on this one so if I get the [__]
cancer from the paper you get the
[__] cancer from the paper yeah
college football onine last night I seen
that yeah M Miami one right they're
winning they're winning pretty big yeah
I don't know what the [__] that be but
who played last night I have no idea I
don't gives a f that's the Church of
What's it's too confusing it's every
week and some people but it's what it's
all about it's where the [__] money's
at man a lot of people like college I
used to I watch it yeah I just don't
know what the [__] going on a lot of
people like it better than Pro and I
they say like the players are playing
for more I I like I I like watching
professional I like watching people who
get paid best the players play for white
women when you're black that's what
you're playing for those white little
chili from [__] small towns when
you're a pro you don't give a [__] you
got money you get whatever color you
want black white Chinese a Filipino
chick from the hospital from the
hospital yeah that's uh that's something
I I I never got into man but I don't
understand how they there was something
in La a couple weeks ago how the
quarterback of USC was on a billboard
promoting getting to sell tickets but it
was near UCLA and they got all upset but
I don't understand how colleges like
this can make millions of dollars off of
the players and then they don't get paid
and and that's why some players have to
go and do other things on the side and
they got to suck dick and strip get the
[__] out of here they got envelopes like
everybody else it's these little rats
that you know little third bench guys
that rat on the other guys let me tell
you something would you play for free
for a [__] education yeah you know
most Americans would but trust me they
got something else going down there for
your ass no just about [__] free they
got to give you something else listen
come on down play some ball we'll give
you a little you ever watch a movie
oneon-one no what's that it's an old mov
with Robbie Benson about a small time
allamerican that goes to a big [__]
school and it's like nothing he sits at
the end of the bench like he was this
big time [__] kid and all of a sudden
they torture him he's too short but he
has a job [__] $50 an hour the
teacher would suck his dick you know he
had he had perks you know what I'm
saying and in those days a teacher could
suck a dick with a clean conscience yeah
now a teacher sucks a dick she's got to
worry she can't sleep and then she got
to toss and turn these little [__]
are going to rat her out yeah there was
one in Texas that that got caught having
sex to like five students listen there
was one when I was growing up in North
Bergen that sucked everybody's dick
she's still Anonymous she you know now
everybody's getting caught all these
kids go home and they [__] crack
because she won't give them a game or
whatever in my day you got your dick
sucked in the be and everybody was
[__] happy you know yeah nobody
[__] complain these little [__]
[__] today they go home Mommy the
teacher sucked my dick what the [__] is
wrong with you how you going to cop to
that [__] you don't say a [__] word
somebody sucks your dick you but these
[__] weaklings today you know what
are you going to do they're too busy
they got to get their dick sucked and
get on the skateboard you know what I'm
saying what do you think like why is it
such a huge difference between female
teachers with with guys and and male
teachers with girls like because a
female could suck your dick when you're
12 and it ain't creepy a guy could touch
your titty and it's [__] creepy when
you're 14 you can't do that [__] but
listen like I said there was never I
grew up in a different time there was
never a [__] sexual deviant guy in my
school but there was some sexually
deviant [__] teachers I was an ugly
guy so the chick didn't want to suck my
dick you know she didn't suck my dick
I'm not going to sit here and tell you
she blew me the teacher that was sucking
dick in high school school never sucked
my dick you know she sucked other
people's dick but I was an ugly [__] so
they didn't bother me but none of those
kids till today that nobody knows about
that teacher that teacher is still
[__] teaching and dancing and
whatever she's about 60 now she ain't
sucking no more dick but back in the day
she was giv head in our school that's
just the way it works out that's it what
are you going to do you know what I'm
saying I don't know nothing about I
don't know about no [__] Billboards
why you talk to me about Billboards and
quarterbacks this is the church what's
happening I don't know nothing about
this [__] all I know is who covered the
[__] spread that's all that you need
to know about sports that's it anything
else is background [__] music when I
was a kid I'd sit there for hours and
watch baskball and then as you get older
you got other [__] going on and you
don't watch that much like I don't watch
that much baseball till October I like
baseball but if you think I'm going to
sit there all [__] summer long with a
hat and a kazoo at my house doing a wave
solo and I went to a couple Dodger games
they're a [__] blast I might go to
one I go to Costco I get two [__]
tickets for 25 bucks yeah they sell and
you get Flor tickets and you and they
give you a hot dog and a [__] soda
Jesus Christ yeah I love baseball but it
just you can't you have to be there
watching it on TV is murder ah you go to
the game you smoke a [__] num I went
a couple weeks ago let me tell you
something those hot dogs they'll go
right through your [__] eating a hot
dog until they and and they gave you
like the first one the first one I took
a bite of them it tasted like tofu then
my uncle goes no no no no no no don't
eat those you got to eat the [__] all
beef ones the all beef ones tasted worse
than the other ones then they had a
higher level the Black Angus ones let me
tell you something there was no Angus in
that [__] dog it was just black I
mean the hot dog was even [__] gray
so forget about eating the only thing
about DOD is they have like a they have
other type of restaurants they have mean
garlic fries but you know what man you
go to those things you eat a hot dog or
so I'm already [__] full the games
are at seven yeah you know what I did my
uncle's a [__] peanut guy so he ate
92 [__] bags of peanuts my uncle you
know he's 76 from Cuba old school that
[__] eats more peanut there was
a Ari shafia is the only Jew that could
eat a peanut like it's the end of the
world the UFC we'll get [__] stoned
and he'll buy a bag of [__] those
peanuts with the shells yeah I love
those my uncle killed him my uncle did
three bags in [__] N9 in Jesus Christ
I helped him you know I'm not going to
sit here and tell you that he was a
[__] solo artist that he was you know
he was Joe Perry when he left eriol
Smith speaking of eriol Smith you know
what I never broke down that album the
full way and I feel bad the album of the
week this week by the way the Church of
with happening now is coming at you two
times a [__] week Monday early to get
your week going nice and Wednesday early
in the midweek sometimes you fall behind
you forget to wipe your ass it's [__]
Wednesday and also Uncle Joey shows up
and says hey it ain't that [__] bad
of a day it's a beautiful [__] day to
be alive by the way it's Monday I love
being home Monday mornings if you have a
good Monday morning it makes the rest of
the week go by early people always say
to me oh you don't work Sundays in com
you know why because I want to be in my
bed [__] Sunday night so Monday
morning I wake up play a little [__]
uh Tony Bennett I want to be around play
a little Tony Bennett I want to be
around every Monday when I was a kid
every day when I was a kid i' go to my
mother's
bar and she open up the door turn off
the [__] alarm and she go to the Juke
Box turn on that turn on the [__] uh
little game that you go back and forth
and uh on Mondays especially she get a
glass of water put on the table and and
she play I want to be around cuz it was
her and my father's song when they came
from Cuba you know I don't know when
Tony Bennett wrote the [__] thing but
uh she would play that first every day
out of respect for my father this it
says it was the number 14 billboard hit
in 1963 that's tremendous play the
[__] song now you want to be Casey
Cas some cocksuck that's what it says on
YouTube all right 63 that's the year I
was born I didn't know that it was in'
63 so every time my mother would go to
the [__] bar she'd play this song
first just to give uh a reference to my
father so every Monday mornings what I
do is I get up early I make the coffee I
clean the [__] litter boxes and I uh
get on here and I play I want to be
around and I respect every [__]
Monday morning and I love it sometimes I
do it during the week too first thing
Lee what are you looking for nothing it
doesn't want to play give me a second
keep talking you know it's right there
Le it's two clicks away it's on I'm
clicked on it it's just the video is not
playing give me a second keep talking I
thought you got the [__] un verse I
did [__] sucker this what I'm talking
about I got a watch Lee even though he's
Jewish I love him to De but I got to
watch them we're bringing back the
yamaka people this week we're going to
have it online [__] you pay me the new
yamaka line from Uncle Joey tremendous
nice little white yam would [__] you pay
me they know exactly where you're coming
from cuz let me tell you what the thing
about it is in life you know a lot of
people are are kind of half a phony cuz
they want people to know or people to
lure or they they want people to think
that they're nice [__] or
whatever I always I'm how I am I curse
in front of people how I am because I
want people to know where they coming
from when you're friends with me this is
what the [__] expect this is why I'm
like here you go some good [__] music
moood in the
morning cuz I got a picture of these
guys here I grew up with that's Dominic
special Darren Rego and Anthony [__]
Bano and they're dead and they died when
we were young this is the first thing I
look at the morning I get in the [__]
good mood cuz they're not here so I got
to do what the [__] they're not doing so
I got to cover the spread today that's
the mentality of the Church of what's
happening now you're thinking Joy where
the [__] are your glasses my glasses I
don't want to be like one of those black
basketball players you see these
[__] for it all started about
20 years ago like
all these [__] uh actors once they
get a little older they start wearing
glasses and and I can see the hus the
wife saying you look so sophisticated
and so smart wear the [__] glasses so
they started with that [__] now I
got Kobe I got the guy in [__] Miami
everybody's wearing [__] point deex
the glasses for $99,000 to look more
intelligent get it together [__]
you're a basketball player not a
scientist all right the [__] little
Halloween costume ain't gonna work
[__] what you gonna do I got drop
some knowledge on these [__]
early because I'm not they think I'm
over here [__] around did you work
out yesterday Lee yeah I did uh what did
you do I was supposed to have a training
session but uh the woman apparently has
too many trainers so I went over to the
gym at my complex and I'm just starting
out guys I don't know if anyone else is
starting out working out too I haven't
worked out I wrestled all throughout
high school and I probably haven't
worked out since I start since wrestling
season stopped my senior year so that's
probably like six or seven years so I'm
starting out fresh and I'm I'm doing the
the stationary bike for like half an
hour and I can do the elliptical for
about 10:15 and then I then I I pass out
but that's all you [__] need to get
the party started what you want to do is
a fat guys get the [__] blood going
that's what I had to do I mean they
threw me out of the wire the first time
I walked in there really the [__]
little trainer cuz you sign up for the Y
in Hollywood and you go down there and
they give you like an evaluation to see
where the [__] you're at so I thought I
was still like in high school I went in
like seven eight years I went right
after the longest
short I thought I was still in high
school I could do a thousand jumping
Jackson [__] he put me on the treadmill
to start and put it up like 1.5 let me
tell you something my friend at the 4
minute Mark I tapped out he was a little
cute little gay guy goes listen dog I
love you to death but don't come back
here till you stop smoking cigarettes
till you start getting it together you
can't even walk in a treadmill so that's
where I [__] started yeah you know I
started at 4 [__] 15 where you walk a
half a block and your joints hurt your
knees hurt your feet so I put the whole
training session in my head I I Knew by
going to the [__] wine that they have
a a heated pool so I just started going
to the heated pool and I would run back
and forth and I would swim bro and I
would swim 15 minutes 20 minutes then I
got cocky and I overslept one night and
I jumped into the Olympic pool because
in bold I used to be part of the master
swimming program what's that the master
swimming program is where you go at 6:00
in the morning and at 6:00 at night and
the lady's name was Jane and she would
just work you like a [__] like a
[__] slave in the water and she right
before I got locked up in prison there
was a UPS guy at the Herz where I worked
at and he was in great shape and I said
how' you get in that [__] shape and
he goes I started going to the master
swiming program stop with the [__]
volumes already saying it's too low a
these [__] people always say it's too
low put your ear next to the [__]
like when you were a kid and your mother
was on in the other room like when you
listen to Richard PRI album so uh you go
at 6:00 in the [__] morning in
Boulder Colorado on the dead of the
[__] winter and the pool would be
outside and they'd be surrounded by snow
where they shoveled and you'd have to
[__] dress yourself in a little Hut
and [__] run out and jump in a pool
and you have to do two of those a day a
day three times a [__] week and she
would train you for little triathlons
not triathlons the double ones the ones
where you swim and jump up and down for
a half hour not really like all three of
them ride your bike that's a triathlon M
tree so I always like [__] swimming
not to mention I'm Cuban you know you
know me I swam around the [__] Island
as a young man like a Savage [__]
oh Jesus so uh I went back and I jumped
into the Olympic pool and that's when I
almost drowned I almost drowned into
that's a scary story man I I don't know
if people have heard it do you want to
tell it again or [__] no I almost
drowned I went to the W I jumped the
[__] in the pool and you know what when
you go into a training pool it's heated
but when you go into a regular Olympic
pool it's not [__] heated it's a
different it's 30° so first thing you it
surrounds your lungs you can't [__]
Breathe Here I am in the middle of the
pool my fat legs were just [__]
moving I wasn't going nowhere dog I I
just was spinning around like a
[__] swimming is tough I mean
it's uh I I used to swim I used to I I
mean I was never really in shape when I
wrestled but I was more in shape and you
run around the track and you I I played
football and you run around the thing
and running and swimming are two
different things swimming is tough It's
especially when you're out of shape it
really shows you when you're out of
shape like wow I am out of shape but it
gets you in the best shape the problem
with swimming in the exercise doesn't go
with you the rest of the day like when
you run for a half hour at 6:00 in the
morning that raises your metabolism it
goes at you you release sweat when you
go in the pool it burns the most
calories per minute okay but when you
get out of the pool you don't take it
with you as much it doesn't burn like
throughout the whole [__] day that's
the problem with swimming a lot of
people don't know that okay you know
what I'm saying so as long as I worked
out yesterday had a good time I went
over there I got in the treadmill I hit
the bag for half hour then I got on the
treadmill uh and ran that did the Mike
doce uh 2 minutes on and half and a 30
minutes 30 seconds of running and I got
on the bike to close it up look at that
shirt [__] swelly right next to you I
might eat some sushi I ain't got I got
dick going on today you know what I'm
saying oh yeah it's it's rough man I
mean it's uh there's not much there's
not much going on out there I mean I'm
working on a TV show but everything
that's going to be in Productions in
production and I feel bad for you guys I
mean there's not that much shooting
right now I don't give a [__] about that
we're always doing something l what the
[__] that the show is about getting up
in the [__] morning and going there
that there and tackling the [__]
everything you just got to make it
happen there's always action out there
you got to just get up you got to get up
with the [__] mentality You' seen
Trading Places the brothers at the end
of the floor Mortimer is on the floor
dying he goes your brother's dying [__]
them we got to do what the [__] we do
here you follow me so don't worry about
the [__] Weight Watches or whatever
the big topic that I've been hearing
about lately is just all the blanco
let's break it down I've never been
[__] impressed with the Cocaine
Cowboys and I'll tell you why because
they talking about it in 1979 you know I
would go to Miami in 1970 as a kid my my
mother baptized a girl down there and I
would go down there and spend time with
them in the summer I loved them ralo and
Vivian Vivian was a school teacher Ral
was a construction Mogul he would go
into we we built all that [__] the uh
the falls in Miami it's the north sou as
they say Southwest 100th Avenue and 130
that was s and8 and I go down there we
clear bushes me and the Son and the
daughters and we do the whole thing now
at night the three kids would go to
sleep and I would hang out with ralo so
ralo knew my father I mean he grew up
with my father and he always assumed
that I knew what my father did so when I
would go down there I would stay with
with in the middle of the night he go
come on let's take a ride and we go
to laita in Miami is little [__] it's
a gas station that doesn't sell gas it
they just sell beer milk and bread okay
and cigarettes and you can go there late
night but it's the coldest [__] beer
you'd ever have we drive out toita and
he getting a [__] he get me a soda
but he let me drink out of his cold Bud
wise that was like a big tree for me go
to his boat and we get on the boat we go
out like 10 [__] miles out and he'd
pick up bales of weed this in the 70s
and then we drive him back in like
nothing it was like stealing like they
would float into this thing he knew the
people and that's what he did for a
living you know and I remember going
down there when I when you watch because
Jazelle with the documentary they talk
about how she ran [__] in Miami in ' 79
by the [__] 79 was when I started
started doing blow what happened in 79
also this all went down in 79 but what
happened in 79 was Marios came in those
[__] Cubans that started killing
130,000 Cubans Fidel let them out of
their jails in 1979 130,000 130,000 100
100,000 of them were [__] uh in jail
and these weren't you know like for
smacking their wife or something these
[__] were omoro this [__]
jail where you walk around half nak and
there's a hole in the middle of the
[__] floor and you got to go pee and
[__] in that [__] hole people tack
you in take you in the [__] hole [__]
in the ass Happ as [__] so these were
the type of criminals that came over
this are the type of criminal you know
when he in Scarface they show the hand
they call the Yaba quas and these people
were [__] nuts for example my my
stepfather's name is Mento which means
four WIS and he had three brothers two
of them came from Cuba at that time and
four of his nephews three of his nephews
within the first year four out of three
out of four nephews were dead and they
shot his both both his brothers Jesus
because they didn't know anything else
they came out here and got into the
[__] cocaine business and by that
time it became bar hille that's where
her claim to fame was that she shot now
let me explain something to you I
watched the first documentary and I
bought into it and bought not and then
the second one was just a waste of my
[__] time but it's funny cuz the
other night when it happened I read it
in the afternoon and I went out not
thinking nothing of it and I went out
and Rogan called me that night he goes
he he they shot jela Blanco and I go
[__] her and we started laughing it's
like you know what the lady killed or
supposedly killed all these [__]
people a 2-year-old kid
you know what she was walking around
knowing it was coming so speaking of
opium one of the things we want to talk
about is losing weight that's right
Joey's lost a lot of weight and you guys
can't see me but I've I've lost about 40
lbs but I need to lose about another 100
something like that and Joey's been one
of the best guys for me since we've
gotten together taking me through it cuz
like the the usual diet I'm sure a lot
of guys out there listening or girls
right now listening have weight issues
and a lot of the diets and weight and
working out it just sucks so Joey has
the oatmeal what else do you usually eat
all every day if you're put a banana in
me I'll [__] put a little oatmeal in
me a little Special K and then uh I go
for a little walk at about 8:30 when I
take my wife to work and then as the day
goes for I'm a I'm basically a Weight
Watchers guy I'm always looking for new
[__] recipes you know I got the do
chap books so listen man uh it's like my
religious beliefs I'm a Catholic but I
try to borrow from the [__] Jews I
throw a little Buddhism in there you
know saying little Santa Ria I put it
all together it's like the gun DOA
[__] religions this is like the gun
DOA diets so I do the doce diet and I do
the Weight Watches diet put together and
then you work out like a [__]
and on the other side you know it's
funny because when I first I was
weighing 4:15 and for a month I would go
box in the morning at Fortune's gym and
I I'd uh hit the bag and I'd [__] uh
there a MAA Foley would train me in the
in the ring M and I did that for a while
I wasn't lo I lost 15 lbs in in 60 days
and then I read something online that
talked about that you could jump up and
down for 92 [__] hours a day but if
you're not uh eating correctly that's
the whole thing you got to eat correctly
and I read it and it made sense and I
had gone to a heart doctor and that
[__] guy said to me you know he goes
Joey you've been coming in here for a
while uh my heart's strong but he goes
you you're too heavy your heart's strong
he goes you should do something why
don't you
go to see uh what's that diet not when
they put the [__] Staple in your
stomach but the other one when they sh
your stomach gastro bypass he goes you
should look into it and he goes that he
would he could talk to a doctor and give
it to me at cost and they could do
payments and I said you know what that's
about 90 [__] needles that's 2,000
[__] I can see me fainting the whole
[__] week I go forget about that [__]
so before I I I looked into it I had a
friend Maron Martinez who died a couple
years ago of cancer God bless or so but
uh she was on Weight Watches and she
lost a ton of [__] weight for a
while so I remember just walking into
Weight Watches and it was just making
little [__] changes it wasn't making
bro let me tell you something a fat [__]
like me Stoner could lose weight anybody
could lose weight because it's basically
just switching it around I I I went from
eating you know this was my old
breakfast my old breakfast was like
three eggs sunny side up a half a pack
of bacon you know toast I had about
three cans of Coco Cola that was my old
breakfast and that was like whatever
what what I would eat with my wife at uh
at 8:00 you know 7:30 soon as she went
to work or I smoked a [__] joint I'd
go to McDonald's and get a number one
with a [__] Coke jeez you know and
two apple pies and then I'd smoke more
pot and i' go eat Chinese with my
friends you know and Chinese will
[__] uh will fatten you the [__] up
you know especially the Chinese Ai and
then I'd go home and eat the leftovers
from the night before and then I'd have
dinner with my wife now my wife is from
the [__] South you know my wife will
fry it if you let her that [__] will
fry a [__] piece of bread if you
[__] you know so uh we go home and
she' make a huge dinner okay and then I
go out go to The Comedy Store and I
drink
coca-colas oh K and I drink 10 or 12
coca-colas you know all night at the bar
with no alcohol in it then I go home and
on the way home you got to stop and get
a taco or milkshake something so it was
really easy so with wait laes I went
from that diet to basically one egg a
piece of toast three slices of bacon and
a bowl of oatmeal and a bunch of fruit
see the Weight Watches diet I did before
see I I write everything down M so the
Weight Watches diet I did before they
had fruit was points but I'm sitting
there going fruit's no points it pushes
the [__] out of your ass so I cheated I
just ate as much fruit as I could I went
through [__] apples to bananas to to
to peaches like I just ate a banana this
fruit's the key like if you're over 350
lbs weight watch it says to eat fruit
seven [__] times a day and that's
tough man that that's tough but not
really that's an apple here a banana
there a pineapple [__] here you know
that that's really tough but you know
what I dropped 100 lb I went all the way
to 270 uh in the last 14 months I've put
on 30 lb I'm up to 300 I walk around at
297 uh by the time the baby's born I'd
like to be down at 250 245 you know my
head's going to be [__] ginormous if
you think you know my head my nose all
you see is [__] nose and he coming at
you and that's one thing they never had
a diet for is the [__] coconut yeah
you know and let me ask you cuz you're a
comic and you would on the road and
being out at night my big problem is I
work a lot and and the I would there's
nothing easier than a drive-thru after
you work 8 10 hours a day you don't
really want to go home and cook now
you're not doing that but you're out on
the road you're out late at the store
you don't want to come home and start
cooking a meal so you stop at McDonald's
or whatever is it just changing your
mindset or how did you get to doing
Weight Watchers with that sort of
stuff you just have to decide what the
[__] you want to do you know if you're
going to McDonald's and all those places
you're shooting yourself in the [__]
foot anyway you're shooting yourself in
the [__] foot if you're going to
McDonald's constantly you know what I
you have to I don't understand how
McDonald's is still in business with
everything I read I don't understand how
you got these little [__] kids and I
see him going into McDonald's one thing
about me guys if you look at my pictures
if I could find pictures of me as a
child that was always Scrappy I was
skinny I didn't get [__] fat till my
35s 32s really yeah I used to walk
everywhere I would walk you know I
believe in [__] exercise but I got
what's called sleep at me with the one
of the worst things you can [__] do
is stay up late especially if you have
to get up early which is part of your
problem yeah I'm working night so it's
it's tough it is man plain and simple
it's whatever the [__] you want to do
you want to lose the [__] weight you
lose the [__] weight I'm I'm telling
you that it's not hard at all to [__]
lose weight it's harder in your mind
people think it's harder in your mind
because Weight Watchers teaches you for
example there's a place Roma [__]
Pizza up here that they make sandwiches
okay now you could go in there we could
get a sandwich two sides chips and a
soda or you go in there and get splitter
sandwich get one side of red peppers in
ol oil which the only thing that has
points is the olive oil which is good
for you yeah and maybe get a you know a
glass of water or something you could
still eat I can still go to [__] uh
In-N-Out burger and get a burger a
cheeseburger single with lettuce tomato
no mayonnaise and no [__] special
sauce I could either half order of fries
cuz the burger with the points is eight
I could e a half order of fries which is
four and then get a diet soda so I just
want to In and Out for 12 points as
opposed to two burgers two burgers a
double double fries a milkshake a soda
and you know what at first you look at
this meal and you go ah I'm going to be
[__] hungry blah
blah but you're not after you finish
there you're not hungry at all you're
like what the [__] man if I could do
this all the time it wouldn't be that
bad you know what I'm saying yeah one
thing you said to me when we started is
go like going to Subway which is you can
get healthy food there but when you go
in there I always think oh I'm going to
want the the foot long when you eat the
foot long you're full if you had gotten
the 6 in and waited 10 minutes you're
going to be full it's enough food if you
eat the 6in butt let me tell you
something man and I and I'm a [__] uh
I've always liked the best food I always
that's one thing about me my mother did
not like let me eat fast food okay you
know I'm from Jersey I had [__] I grew
up around great deli oh I would never
let myself on a [__] like I was in
Nashville and there was a Subway and I
go let me go get a tuna how bad could
the [__] tuna be it's [__] bad you
know I'm sitting there one day like any
other Stoner on [__] the world and
I'm watching a commercial and they're
talking about the turkey jalapeno
avocado sandwich oh delicious it sounds
delicious it has a delicious sandwich if
you take thumans [__] oven roasted
turkey and you slice that [__]
thin and you get a nice avocado and smme
it you put some jalapenos maybe a piece
of provalone that's a [__] Dynamic
sandwich right there but when you go to
[__] uh Subway or quiz
you taste that sandwich and it's that
[__] turkey salami [__] how you going
to eat how do you call this a spicy
Italian this is a spicy [__] turkey
this ain't no spicy town all that you
leave there and an hour later you're
burping [__] coold Cuts like a
[__] you're not supposed to be
burping [__] Coke Cuts never so
that's the reason why I don't go to
Subway I know that Jared said he lost
weight with Subway wait 5 years enough
he's got a hemorrhoid the size of
[__] Mount uus coming out of his
[__] yeah cuz all that [__] will
[__] kill you and the lettuce is
petrified sometimes it's just a little
petrified you all that sh you see the
[__] people that work at Subway they
forget to put their gloves
on the worst thing for me customer
service in restaurants is to an alltime
[__] and and it's not even customer
service at a restaurant it's customer
service [__] anywhere you walk into
these place and these kids just look at
you like you're a [__] three-headed
[__] monster you know just either
help me or don't [__] help me I go in
the stores looking to [__] spend a
dollar and I look at who's working there
and how they treat you and I've always
said that in this economy right now
customer services was going to Prevail
yeah you know everybody has a cheap
price look at [__] uh Amazon you
could do is uh you could [__] do
Amazon for [__] nothing go on get
delivery to your house you don't have to
leave stay home and mind your [__]
business and that's it you know what I'm
saying do you think it's commissioned
because like Best Buy in all those
places they don't make commission
anymore so what what is their incentive
to sell what best best buyers any of
those electronic places any store I
don't know of any stores that give that
work on commission anymore do you yeah
people work on Comm I used to work at
[__] foot locks a lot of that's what
I'm saying I'm I think in the past they
but I know at least at the big
electronic stores they don't work on
commissions so that's why they don't
know anything and they don't actually it
was on Louis the other night the other
night he uh he went into a store and a
Salesman didn't know anything about it
and then when he got when louby didn't
want to help him out he uh the salesman
tripped him and it it was hilarious but
it brought up a good point that what's
their incentive to sell it's why in at
good restaurants when servers can make
money you're going to get good service
at least in my experience I don't know
what do you think the [__] are you
talking about I don't know man I've been
up all night well if you go to [__] a
nice restaurant and and they know you're
going to [__] listen you should always
[__] tip B let them like my mother my
mother would get into a cab and throw
the [__] at 20 just to know
where she stood with the [__]
before she even put the pedal to the
metal [__] you know so they know
where you stand you know where you stand
you you go to a bar sometimes the bar is
packed you throw that bartend to a
[__] 10 spot and a and a bud and a
rock or something they could stand
around me yelling me me me me me you're
going to still get the [__] cocktail
first that's old school type mentality
that's Church of What's Happening Now
you walk in there you give that [__]
guy a butt you slip in his hand like a
soldier and you see what happen speaking
of [__] Church what's happening now
let's break over for some [__] uh
Jesus [__] cookies here I got these
things last night they're like one 20
th000 grams of [__] reefer and little
these are the new church of what's
happening now uh is that a edible yeah
these are little Edibles uh holy [__]
they're really uh they're really uh what
do you call those Jolly ranch is what
you call them oh good lord you [__]
take them like this and right now if
you're at home get on your hands and
knees so I can throw a [__] blessing
on you and [__] you know uh Jesus Took
the [__] juice passed around his
friends and said drink from it the Holy
Blood this is my [__] blood the new
and everlasting blood drink of it and
you'll live for [__] ever and then he
took the after dinner he took the
[__] bread and he broke it and he
gave it to his disciples and said take
this all of you and drink of it or eat
of it this is my body the true an
everlasting body of mad [__]
flavorit so here it is Boom the church W
throw it [__] that's how we're running
here today where these cats come see
your dad you [__] come here mama none of
these cats are coming out Le's here
today Lee what did you get a hooker last
night or something you got the [__]
you came in here that you put the Malo
on them you know what I'm saying I'm
sorry man usually they like me I don't
know what's going on come on come on
greay Gray you don't want to say hello
to the camera
[__] and I'm going to show you
this is gray this my girl mhm oh gray is
great there's my gray gray
guys there's my little
girl she's not that little either she's
about [__]
10 I love her with all my heart this is
my little gray gray say hello [__]
suers say hello gray gray what's
happening I know I'm not the mic Le so
what turned it up I turned it up man
they get it Jesus Christ they got to see
what the beautiful cat is I can't have a
m say hello Mama now gray has an
interesting story right cuz when I first
came over here she was like living in
this room mostly yeah cuz gray used to
live out side and when I moved here gray
started coming up the stairs and saying
hello scratching the door in the
mornings and [__] my other cats will get
[__] pissed but then gray got
attacked by this douchebag [__] cat
who I seen last night he ripped open her
little back oh so uh I couldn't find her
she wouldn't come home so me and my wife
went hunting for gray we found her
around the corner and we brought her
back and and the landlord downstairs
took her to the vet but the problem was
once she came back she wasn't allowed to
go back outside she's already got dogs
downstairs that's right this is my
little girl so I brought her up I didn't
want her to leave she had grown up
around here she knows the ins and out
she's not allowed to go out no more
besides I couldn't have her out look at
her she's my little black and white girl
who says I hate black
people that's right [__]
shuer oh there's always lot order I I
work nights and that's the best part
about working nights is around 2:00
TBS two three but they they cut him down
they've been replacing them with the
[__] Mentalist they pissed me the
[__] off lately a little fidget guy with
the fidget [__] girl you know I like
the show it's a good show but Law and
Order is a stable been around for 25
[__] years you're going to change it
up on me now yeah 2:00 sometimes I come
home I'm running around all afternoon I
want to see Law and Order I get up here
and there's no [__] Law and Order no
and they did that show was on for 20
years and I can't believe they canel it
I mean 25 years that's a lot of residual
money right there a lot of criminals
yeah but then they they tried Law and
Order La for a while and that that can
it's not on I don't think so it's they
canceled it with I love Cool J and the
other if they did they're about to
terrible n you know it's about [__]
real stories we were talking what's the
one we were talking about last night
wasn't it you were talking about low and
Order episode
no don't [__] with me you're trying to
put something out there and you're
trying to change it up on me [__]
Church What's Happening Now Monday
morning I'm happy you're [__] here
last week we were talking about uh Erol
Smith you know I was telling Lee yester
I was telling Eddie Bravo last night
that you know sometime you have all your
life to have a great first album yeah
then your second album usually tells you
what's going on the reason why I like
those older guys especially AOS Smith on
that third album is a masterpiece but so
was the second Al Get Your Wings don't
get us confused here the first one was
dreamon with walking a dog you got one
good song and the other one the second
one was Get Your Wings which is a
[__] Masterpiece cuz they didn't come
out [__] throwing heat right there's
a lot of slower ballads on there Same
Old Song and dances and the slow ballad
but you got train kept the rolling where
they went from a studio version into a
[__] live version but Jesus Christ
[__] rocks you know throw me a song
from rocks anything not back in the
saddle but there's got to be you got
back in the saddle you got nobody's
fault let's see what else let's see if
they have the full album on there maybe
yeah they got the full album rocks here
we go full album All right you pressing
rocks
every's last child rats in the cell
combination sick as a
dog do you have one you want to start
with let's start with nobody's
[__] fault go to the 20 minute
Mark right there all right it's going to
take a while to to link up I know that
but these [__] you do let's see
that's my main man Le Le's one of the
baddest [__] I've known you
know that a lot of people always said
yesterday to me ah Lee's let me tell you
something about Lee Lee got the ball
going Lee's the executive producer on
[__] it's either you or the priest
Lee also helped me with the documentary
The Mad flavor Worlds the mind the Lee
he's a he's a crazy [__] he
wouldn't be doing this he'd be doing
[__] arson he's that type of he' be
lighting buildings down to the [__]
nub that's how he roll Jewish lightning
[__] if you you know one of the
reasons why I got out of crime was one
thing you never want somebody to knock
on your door when you're 50 [__]
years old you know whatever you do at 20
is great you don't want to do time at
[__] 50 and above you don't want to a
[__] can that's a that's a that's a
bad [__] life what is that I the
ghost of the gazela gazela that [__]
sucker so you don't want to end up in
that was the biggest deterrent I had was
seeing my uncle in Miami go to jail at
50 and you know when he went to jail he
was a millionaire and next thing you
know he's got to move into an apartment
in Atlanta because the federal
penitentiaries in Atlanta even though he
was rocking in Miami he had to move to
Atlanta and put his kids in a
two-bedroom apartment three [__] kids
so I see what it does to you I see what
does to your family but the worst thing
is that you don't want to die in the can
and that's the worst thing about Karma
man that you're walking around when you
do something like there's people in
front in front of my house here that
Park and then go to work instead of
parking for free parking they Park back
here cuz they don't want to do the
sticker or some [__] and they park in
front of my house every [__] day I
wake up and I see the same cars and I
want to go over and stick a nail in
front of them or flatten their [__]
tire or scratch that door you know my
stepdad was a fanatic of the spot in
front of his [__] house oh yeah of
course on his on his his mind it
belonged to him was it in New York it
was in Jersey in New Jersey and he would
sit there all [__] night watching the
spot and when somebody parking it he'd
go out there and flatten his [__]
tires we got to the point where nobody
would park on the [__] block because
they know their tires would be [__]
flat what are you looking at the [__]
thing for I'm talking to you C I'm sorry
no that's uh so I sit out there
sometimes and I'm like you know what I'm
going to flatten This Guy's Tire today
or I'm was thinking of getting cat [__]
and put put on the door handle you know
at 49 I know one thing if I do that I'm
going to walk around and I got something
coming to me oh yeah I never want
something coming to me that's the
problem with [__] Karma so Jella
whatever rest in peace but dirty [__]
you knew you had to come and you out
there slinging blow getting your [__]
little black [__] suck or Colombian
[__] suck they killed her in front of
her daughter-in-law or some [__] yeah
yeah yeah two people Rod up on a
motorcycle and shot her in the head yeah
[__] New Jack City Style you know
what I'm saying that's nuts I I had a
question I was thinking cuz I read that
article and I was thinking about it the
other day do you know of anybody who's
like has been a drug dealer or doing
that stuff for their entire life life
and actually gets away with it and like
doesn't go to jail end up dead or are
there people who can do that for like a
lifetime or is that a lot of people do
it for a lifetime but there's never you
always pay somewhere okay you're always
going to pay somewhere somewhere you got
to pay for your [__] sense so you
might rock and roll and make some money
but you might have other heartaches that
are associated with that and you know
you know when it's coming my ly had made
a bunch of money but he had a [__]
son and his wife always blamed that
really on the [__] you know what he
had done and I shouldn't say [__] he
was [__] a Momo whatever I don't
[__] know but uh they she always
blamed it on that you got it coming
always remember that the Church of
what's happening now let's play some
[__] musically what are you going to
move for today uh you want to play more
uh black sabath or you want to play
something else I don't know I'm in the
mood for something exotic what do you
[__] think Le like uh hm
we haven't done any real we've done a
little bit of rap but not really or any
country country that's not [__] bad
you know what I'm saying what you know
about I love [__] I don't know [__]
about country I like this uh the the the
the [__] chick and the guy the lady
Al the Bellum I like those [__] two
their Savages don't forget Mr T's
calling in today my high school
teacher's calling in about 20 minutes uh
Mr T is a very interesting guy I love
this guy and I've spoken to him uh I
keep in touch with him he was my teacher
from fresh freshman year the senior year
in high school and pretty much after
that he kept me out of uh he kept me
from [__] taking a Swan Dive as he
would call it you know Joey I hear
through the [__] ranks you're
thinking of taking a Swan Dive it ain't
worth it so uh I didn't see him from the
time I graduated in ' 82 and uh in ' 84
I seen him on a street corner he pulled
up next to me and he goes you looking
like [__] morto van death warmed over
look at you you filthy [__] Savage
look at this bad [__]
so uh he said you know you got to get
your life together you can't keep
hanging out on corners and the next
thing you [__] know uh I had to leave
I had to leave North Bergen New Year's
Eve 1984 New Year's Eve Jesus 1984
because I fronted a half ounce of blow
so I figured i' front the half ounce of
blow keep the pocket money and start a
new life I called him about 6:00 in the
morning he picked me up and uh took me
to cres Gill New Jersey about 15 miles
away and uh he took me to a few AA
meetings and he believed in me you know
and I got a job in the city and I got a
job at a liquor store and I kept [__]
doing my thing so after 2 months one day
he goes I got a call from the cops do me
a favor don't come back till you pull up
with a [__]
Cadillac that's [__] intense I went
to Rascals one time I called him I go I
ain't got no Cadillac but I'm getting on
stage do you want to come and we and
that was about 15 years ago we've been
tight and whenever he sees me on TV he
calls me and he's my high school teacher
wow Mr T and uh I love him to that and
this is the reason I do this [__] you
know to make people like that proud they
want on a limb for me so I'm trying to
go on a [__] limb for them you know
what I'm saying now looking back into
those times when you were when those
people would help you out and you were
still doing crime or still doing drugs
did you feel bad doing that you just
couldn't stop or you just didn't no I
didn't give a [__] why do I give a [__]
you're doing your thing dog when you do
your thing you commit and you don't
[__] look badly you know what I'm
saying when you got to pull out a
[__] gun and say what are you going
to do I mean you know you're caught up
in different things in your life life
you know I made mistakes like everybody
[__] else some women suck 50 [__]
you know I tried to roll the [__] what
are you going to [__] do it happened
sometimes in your life but I'm here to
tell you I wasn't not happy about it now
I'm going to have a child MH I don't
want the [__] kid to know but what
are you going to do the kid's going to
know and you live with it you stick with
your decisions the things we do when you
ain't got a [__] gun Lee how about
little [__] Allison Chains this
morning Down in the Hole direct from the
from the murky Waters the underworld
where there's H there's [__]
everything you understand me and if you
find the live one do it but just go off
of dirt just to get people in the
[__] mood today cuz this show is
about getting you up it's 600 in the
[__] morning what do you think I'm
doing up here I'm here for my [__]
health or what when I was a kid and I
get up that' be the news the news and
jackan doing [__] situps in a
bodysuit like Bruce Lee without the
[__] stripe here you got a bunch of
[__] you [__] got 800 channels
and then you got mad flavor you got it
what what Allison chain song do you want
to play down and up [__]
hole okay great [__] Alum dirt one of
my all-time favorites I mean uh let me
tell you something man I was down and
out with music after the 80s I was like
[__] this [__] and when all that stuff
came out of Seattle I was never so
[__] happy I like that [__] so much I
met a girl moov to [__] Seattle
that's how much I like it sound Gard
Alice and chains I mean all that [__]
[__] Pearl Jam it was just a beautiful
time to be up there and I was is uh very
fortunate too bad I was on probation the
whole [__] time what are you going to
do Le what are you looking for a [__]
crystal ball over there flading man give
me give me 4 seconds loading what do you
got AT&T versus for what are they
[__] loading they're not fast enough
these [__] they charge you for
[__] everything it's going to be the
speed of light and then nothing [__]
happens they're the biggest [__] rip
BS without a gun AT&T Sprint I love them
to death I love my [__] Sprint phone
I don't like this is falling or
something no no I'm saying I'm ready oh
who gives a [__] Lee you th don't do
that Lee cuz you throw me off okay when
you move your head and you tell me I
don't know what the [__] going on
you're in the middle of dropping [__]
knowledge what are you doing look who's
coming [__] is here where the
rest of them Terry
CLK just remember he goes into office
we're really going to get down here
there's going to be no reefer no nothing
but I don't give a [__] look at this I
got the Vaper
pen and worst case scenario you know me
I smoke these [__] cat buds I order
these from [__] Amazon go to Amazon
pet Green's cat in their buds I love
this [__] from my cat they're getting
used to it D out see they get their
resistance like weed every once in a
while you're paying attention for the
phone this [__] might call it's
on whenever he's ready yeah he might
call in a couple minutes so that's how
lucky we are today I still keep in touch
with my high school teachers [__]
suckers we're going to have to get Baron
to call if anyone watch the documentary
Baron was on in the guy with the red
shirt in the blue background he's great
that's a good [__] idea I'm going to
have uh the the stripper call I called
her this morning she ain't [__]
answering I wanted to see what her deal
was wait that [__] freak up and talk
about hand jobs and whatever the [__]
she does who's this [__] send an
email this early about travel they send
you this [__] about travel.com who
gives a [__] if you keep sending me
emails after a year and I don't get back
to you why you sending me why are you
wasting your time you think I'm going to
change my [__] mind about your
product now I got Boston Market sending
[__] emails you get their emails come
out to Boston Market yeah listen man B
when you're a fat [__] Boston Market's
got great
turkey you go there you get a little
slice of [__] turkey with a little
stuffing you know you get double sides
of meat you get extra protein you put
that trip to [__] Norm in your system
you go home and take a nap you smoke a
[__] blunt so it's not bad because
you're not going to make a [__]
turkey every week turkeys dry too much
though man I I tend to stay away from it
like a turkey dinner I'll have turkey
sandwiches but turkeyy dry too much yeah
but the problem is cuz you're ordering a
turkey dinner on a [__] Wednesday by
that anything's [__] dry her [__]
is [__] dry you got to eat the turkey
dinner when it's fresh on a Sunday even
a no ho whole CC down the [__] corn
no ho whole CC a no ho whole Diner which
you ordered the spaghetti and found out
how bad the [__] food was they got a
great turkey on Sunday they slice it
thin the mashed potatoes blow the
[__] gravy looks like pimple juice
like rad pimple juice that hits the
[__] mirror it's thick but uh he's
calling no not yet what are you looking
at me for like I'm on probation
[__] looking at you r i I get
yelled at when I look at the chat I get
yelled at when I look at you man I don't
know what the [__] you're doing you're
confusing me here you know what I'm
saying and everybody's everybody
everybody that you saw last night listen
I don't know how to break this down for
you cuz people going to get pissed off
and I don't give a [__] and here goes
all right when I turn out that
Democratic Convention last night and I
seen that Puerto Rican Mexican dude and
his last name is Castro I almost shot
myself that was a [__] weak move
putting up a [__] Castro that's
Castro that [__] talked to people
took over a [__] Island and shoved up
that [__] ass and it's never going I
hate Castro everything yeah Castro
convertibles I hate
the I hate Castro I hate them [__]
all so I got pissed off but thank God my
girl and you know what I'll tell you
what I always think this election was
going to be won by the women on this one
cuz they're [__]
close I thought Obama's wife was going
to go up there and throw a p i love Mrs
Obama so don't get me wrong oh that
[__] thing was brutal she that was
that that [__] speech was giving me
an he beat talking about her family and
walking up the stairs and seeing her
father who gives a [__] all right let me
know what your husband's going to do I
got to sit through this [__] that's
one of those cocaine ear beting when you
want the chick to suck your dick but you
got to let her tell a story to get there
you know what I'm saying she's talking
about her father coming home and she'd
be on the top of the stairs do I need
this [__] aggravation in my life just
lick my nuts and move on with your
[__] long story yeah no I I can't
stand this time of year I I get yelled
at all the time cuz I just don't vote
they're all liars you got to go [__]
vote but they're all [__] Liars at
least you see through it I mean you know
the big question is how much has your
life changed before [__]
[Music]
years
oh
[Music]
yeah